he is going to blame someone
other than himself for all of
the investigations.
We will see.
>>> Meantime, the threat of
Chinese invasion is playing into
this, invasion of Taiwan is
growing.
If that happens the U.S. Has
vowed to fight in Taiwan's
defense.
A battle between China and the
U.S. Over the self-governing
island nation could result in
devastating mutual losses which
is one of the reasons Taiwan is
a critical interest to both
superpowers.
Will Ripley joins us with more.
Hello, will Ripley from Taipei.
Tensions rising across the
Taiwan strait.
Where do things stand between
China and the U.S.?
>> Reporter: Are the united
States under former president
trump and president Biden has
been selling Taiwan billions of
dollars in weapons more than
ever before, trying to get
weapons into this island so it
could defend itself potentially
if China were to make a move.
You heard the former president
talking about he being able to
prevent World War III while CNN
with this submarine deal with
Australia and the United Kingdom
is hoping there will be
deterrence in this region and
underwater power to prevent
China from making a move on
Taiwan.
>> Reporter: Chinese fighter
jets streaming over the skies.
Military ships sailing off its
coast.
Daily occurrences for Taiwan.
Living under the constant threat
of a possible Chinese attack.
Beijing's communist leader
claims Taiwan as part of its
territory despite having never
ruled it.
Tensions rising across the
Taiwan strait since Nancy
Pelosi's visit in August, the
first visit in 25 years.
>> We will not abandon our
commitment to Taiwan.
>> Reporter: China's response,
days of large-scale military
drills encircling the island,
firing ballistic missiles over
Taiwan.
Analyst fear this may be
repeated again next month.
Taiwan's president Tsai ing-wen
expected to meet U.S. House
speaker Kevin Mccarthy.
>> Are you saying that the
United States would come to
Taiwan's defense if --
>> Yes.
We have a commitment to do that.
>> Reporter: The U.S. Has
reasons to worry about a Chinese
invasion of Taiwan.
Protecting valuable
semiconductor chips.
Taiwan is a global leader.
Tiny chips that power frefrg
computers to stars.
The island producing 70% of
global supply.
Defending democracy.
Losing to communist China would
shatter stability.
Protecting U.S. Alliances.
Asian countries would face a
more powerful China with little
freedom of speech.
The stakes are high.
But experts believe there is
reason for optimism.
>> Do you think the U.S. And
China are headed in a positive
optimistic direction?
>> The idea that conflict
between the U.S. And China is
inevitable I strongly disagree
with that.
>> Reporter: Meaningful channels
of communication between the
U.S. And the prc helps us
minimize unknowns, minimize
confusion and misunderstands and
thes good for Taiwan.
U.s./china relations on a
downward spiral since that
suspected Chinese spy balloon
bursting months of beijing/d.c.
Diplomacy.
The U.S. And Taiwan get even
closer.
Taiwan's president and the third
in line to the U.S. Presidency
meeting on American soil.
As tensions escalate, all eyes
will be on China and where is
this all headed.
When you look at the U.S.
Expanding its military presence
in the Philippines, encouraging
Japan to expand their role in
the military.
This nuclear submarine deal, the
United States feels deterrence
in this part of the world is
crucial.
And China's rhetoric is really
sharp.
From XI jinping all the way
down, China is blasting the
United States and it's
apparently the external
messaging matches what the tone
is internally.
They haven't reestablished lines
of communication since the U.S.
Shot down the spy balloon.
>> No, they haven't.
They haven't had those
conversations.
We were just talking to Natasha
about that earlier.
And while we are seeing
president Biden taught the
submarine deal, it's not a
surprise, they announced this 18
months ago, was a big deal then.
Now that it's coming to
fruition, this is happening with
the background of what everyone
in Washington was talking about
this weekend China brokering
this diplomatic deal between
Iran and Saudi Arabia.
>> Reporter: Yeah, you are
seeing these power plays.
The United States, you know, is
supreme when can comes to
underwater power.
So to have nuke submarines now
rotating in Australia in 25
years, Australia can start
producing their own nuclear
snoouks changes the dynamic.
China going to the Middle East
which has been a stronghold of
U.S. Diplomacy and brokering a
deal, not the first, obviously,
between Saudi Arabia and Iran,
but it is a message to the
United States the fact that they
were specific and clear that
none of the language would be in
English when they were doing the
negotiations.
So that goes to show China's
rising influence whether the
negotiations will be successful,
you know, it's also happening in
Africa where China is making
economic investments.
So it's economic and diplomatic
power and military power and you
have the U.S. And allies and you
have China and Russia and other
authoritarian countries gearing
up for this showdown, both sides
trying to outmatch the other.
Will it be deterrence or could
it evolve to something more and